[Música]
cuántos de ustedes aquí presentes
conocen la relación entre este lápiz y
este cassette probablemente las personas
de mi edad o las mayores lo ubiquen
fácilmente pero las personas que
nacieron en las últimas generaciones
quizás no lo tengan tan obvio sin
embargo si les replanteo la pregunta y
les digo cuántos de ustedes conocen para
qué sirven algunas de estas dos
aplicaciones tal vez sean las personas
más jóvenes las que sí sepan el uso de
ellas entonces hoy vengo a compartir con
ustedes algunos de estos fuertes
contrastes que marcan tanto la
generación en la que estamos viviendo
básicamente quiero comenzar esta charla
mostrando una película de charles
chaplin del año 1936 para llevarlos a
través de un viaje en el tiempo donde
vamos a poder notar algunos de estos
fuertes contrastes que les comento
en esta película básicamente se muestra
como un trabajador de la clase obrera
pierde su empleo pierde su empleo debido
a la industrialización y a la producción
en serie que se estaba llevando a cabo
en esos momentos además se vivía la gran
depresión de eeuu entonces al ver esta
película yo me he planteado una pregunta
será que la tecnología no juega a favor
o no juega en nuestra contra con todos
estos cambios que vamos viviendo pero
para contextualizar el concepto de
cambio voy a utilizar la siguiente
analogía permítanme mostrarles esta
imagen como muchos de ustedes deben
saber la materia tiene tres estados
principales el estado sólido el estado
líquido y el estado gaseoso en estado
sólido las moléculas se encuentran
fuertemente unidas y forman redes
cristalinas generando objetos
obviamente sólidos que cuando presentan
algún impacto no presentan deformación
aparente a medida que se le aplica
temperatura o presión a este objeto en
estado sólido
todos conocemos lo que viene a
continuación las moléculas comienzan a
separarse
se puede ver como el objeto pasa a un
estado líquido con las características
de que se puede adaptar fácilmente a
cualquier entorno que está conteniendo
esta sustancia si se prolonga la
aplicación de temperatura o presión pues
básicamente este líquido pasa al estado
gaseoso donde las moléculas
principalmente se expanden en el aire y
ya no tienen mucha fuerza de atracción
entre sí porque utilizó esta analogía
porque había un historiador perdón un
sociólogo llamado zygmunt bauman él nos
hablaba del concepto de modernidad
líquida a qué se refiere con este
concepto él dice que básicamente hoy en
día los vínculos entre las personas y
las relaciones humanas se están viendo
fuertemente afectadas debido a todos los
cambios que estamos viviendo producto
justamente de los avances que se van
dando en distintos campos como en este
caso la tecnología entonces yo quisiera
contarles un poquito mi vivencia
personal con respecto a todos estos
cambios cuando yo era muy pequeño
bastaba con usar mi patineta o mi
bicicleta para salir con mis amigos a
pasarla bien al aire libre nos trepamos
a los árboles jugar
con nuestra onda tirando piedras y demás
éramos unos traviesos pero esto fue
cambiando a medida que fueron llegando
algunos dispositivos tecnológicos a
nuestra ciudad por ejemplo cuando tenía
como cinco años tuve mi primer nintendo
una consola que para mí era fascinante
en la época y yo podía juntarme con mis
primos o amigos del barrio a jugar toda
la tarde y hacíamos campeonatos de
fútbol y demás más adelante con la
llegada del internet y aparecen los
primeros cafés internet en la ciudad
esto va cambiando entonces ya con los
amigos en vez de juntarnos en una casa
para ir a compartir nos íbamos a estos
cafés a hacer lo que se llamaban las
famosas chuzadas que era amanecer se
todas las noches jugando medalla de
honor en distintos juegos de matanzas y
guerras tal vez muchos de aquí seguro
han vivido una buena ley sociedad
más adelante vemos que aparecen consolas
cada vez más inteligentes con el
internet de las cosas y prácticamente
todos los objetos se empiezan a conectar
a la red
entonces ya ni siquiera se vuelve
necesario ir a un lugar donde uno pueda
jugar con estos dispositivos sino que en
tu propia casa puedes estar conectado
con gente de todo el mundo mientras
básicamente pasas un buen rato haciendo
lo que más te guste es el caso de mi
hermano menor que yo lo veo que se tira
varias amanecidas jugando con gente de
irlanda de alemania de suecia entonces
esto me lleva a plantearme una incógnita
será que la tecnología nos permite
conectarnos más con esa gente que están
lejos de nosotros pero que nos está
desconectando de la gente que está cerca
de nosotros irónico no lo creen
cuando yo era joven recuerdo que si
algún profesor nos daba una tarea en el
colegio pero teníamos que recurrir sólo
a dos medios uno de ellos era ir a la
biblioteca municipal de la ciudad y el
otro medio era ingresar a una
computadora y utilizar la enciclopedia
encarta obviamente era una enciclopedia
que tenía muchísima información pero
esta información era muy limitada sin
embargo hoy en día vemos plataformas muy
poderosas como wikipedia donde uno al
alcance de un solo clic puede encontrar
una infinidad de información que antes
no era ni siquiera imaginable cuál es el
gran problema de tener ahora un exceso
de información que cosa que antes no se
daba antes había una falta de
información pues el problema es que toda
esta información que tenemos a nuestra
disposición puede ser información que no
es veraz puede ser información alterada
por cualquier usuario de hecho hasta en
wikipedia cualquier persona puede subir
su contenido entonces uno cuando
descarga información no sabe si esta
información es real hay una anécdota
cuando salió la primera red social
llamada mark recuerdo que yo iba a un
café internet y chateaba con una chica
estaba completamente enamorado
haberla conocido y bueno había una buena
conexión salida del colegio llegaba
directo a la computadora para conversar
con ella y hasta que llega un momento en
el que me dice ok qué te parece si nos
conocemos este fin de semana perfecto
primera vez que nos íbamos a ver en
persona había como les digo un fuerte
vínculo porque chateamos durante más de
tres meses entonces cuando llegamos a
una heladería a encontrarnos por primera
vez
una decepción total para ambos yo no era
lo que ella esperaba ella no era lo que
yo esperaba entonces por eso les digo no
hay que creerse todas las cosas que uno
encuentra en internet
se dice que las personas que nacimos en
estas etapas de transición o de cambio
básicamente somos personas muy flexibles
que nos adaptamos fácilmente a nuestro
entorno y a estos tiempos de cambio por
ejemplo antes vivíamos en una era donde
todos los dispositivos eran analógicos
mecánicos y demás hoy en día estamos
pasando una transición hacia lo que se
conoce como una revolución digital la
digitalización de todos nuestros
productos por ejemplo mi abuela tiene
mucho problema cuando desea hacer una
llamada por teléfono saca su celular y
estaba muy acostumbrada a usar los
antiguos celulares ella prefiere los
grandes botones con teclas y con números
que una pantalla táctil entonces siempre
necesita la ayuda de los nietos para
poder usar este tipo de dispositivos mi
madre
recién abrió un negocio de venta de
productos y no tenía mucho alcance a los
clientes
entonces me pide ayuda para crear una
página de internet yo básicamente le
enseñó cómo crear su página cómo
contactar a algunos posibles clientes y
luego cuando veo la página me doy cuenta
que sólo tenía un like el like de mi
madre
entonces bueno por parte de esta
enseñanza era tratar de transmitirle el
buen uso de este tipo de tecnologías que
tenemos a nuestra disposición y en la
luz la última anécdota sería el caso de
mi padre que muchas veces cuando recibe
un mensaje por correo electrónico en vez
de leerlo en la pantalla él tiene la no
sé si buena o mala costumbre de
imprimirlos los correos para leerlos en
papel
imagínense
entonces un poquito para ir cerrando
quiero hablar de uno de los más fuertes
impactos que está teniendo la tecnología
hoy en día y tiene que ver con la
pérdida de empleos debido a la
tecnificación del trabajo
se cree en muchos lugares del mundo
sobre todo en los países más
desarrollados de que las máquinas nos
están quitando empleo y esto se puede
apreciar en estadísticas de distintos
países es cierto muchas máquinas quitan
el trabajo porque porque las máquinas no
se enferman no hay que asegurar las
trabajan 24 horas al día hacen un
trabajo muy preciso entonces a largo
plazo termina siendo mucho más factible
para una empresa sobre todo industrial
contar con una máquina que contar con
muchas personas en su cuerpo laboral sin
embargo yo como un fanático y apasionado
de la tecnología no vengo a compartir
esta parte triste y negativa de como la
tecnología nos quita el trabajo al
contrario yo vengo a mostrarles cómo la
tecnología puede ser una fuente de
innovación y una herramienta que nos
puede permitir generar nuevos vínculos
con las personas que nos rodean
quisiera compartir con ustedes un caso
por ejemplo un amigo que salió de la
universidad hace un par de años el no
tenía un trabajo previo entonces
obviamente no tenía un currículum aún
muy amplio iba tocando puerta por puerta
hasta encontrar algún trabajo posible lo
rechazaban lo rechazaban y lo rechazaban
entonces él se vio obligado a emprender
su propio negocio él vio que estaba
proliferando en la ciudad lo que son los
negocios de comida informal llamados
food tracks los carritos de comida y se
dedicó al diseño y fabricación de este
tipo de carritos hoy en día le va
bastante bien porque podemos ver que es
un boom en la ciudad y bueno el
construir fabrica este tipo de productos
hace ya más de dos años otro caso son
algunos amigos que se ven obligados a
vender productos por internet negocios
de venta de flores venta de chocolates
venta de muebles etcétera y por último
el caso de un familiar muy cercano que
perdió su empleo hace seis meses atrás y
hasta el día de hoy le es muy difícil
encontrar un nuevo trabajo o una nueva
fuente laboral precisamente porque se ha
desactualizado producto de todos estos
rápidos cambios y hoy en día
prácticamente no es una persona
empleable porque no cuenta con este tipo
de conocimientos en el manejo de
distintas herramientas digitales y
tecnológicas
entonces yo quisiera decirles lo
siguiente vamos a usar una última escena
de la película de charles chaplin donde
se puede ver como la novia o la chica
que con la que salía chaplin durante la
película prácticamente está desahuciada
no quiere seguir adelante y le dice que
no vale la pena entonces él con una
actitud muy positiva le dice no vamos
adelante podemos salir adelante juntos
yo quiero con esa misma actitud positiva
invitar a todos a plantearnos la
siguiente pregunta cómo podemos hacer
para enfrentarnos a un futuro cada vez
más incierto y a todos estos cambios que
se siguen viniendo más adelante pues la
respuesta no la tengo yo pero lo que sí
les puedo asegurar para que no pasemos
de una sociedad líquida a una sociedad
prácticamente gaseosa es que utilicemos
las tecnologías para que juegue a
nuestro favor
generando conexiones entre las personas
que más queremos generando conocimiento
compartiendo el conocimiento
además vincularnos más con nuestros
seres queridos como les decía las
personas mayores a veces se sienten
vulnerables no nos quieren pedir ayuda a
la hora de
y trabajar con algunas de estas
herramientas pero nosotros como
embajadores de la tecnología los jóvenes
de hoy en día tenemos la responsabilidad
y el deber de generar y compartir este
conocimiento muchas gracias
[Aplausos]